>>We need more highly adaptive
solutions on how to help a variety
of children reach these
high standards.
There can be no more top down
one size fits all approach
to school reform.
My name is Barnett Berry and I'm the
founder and President of the Center
for Teaching Quality, a policy
research organization that's
dedicated to advancing a twenty first
century results oriented profession.
Waiting for Superman
is a powerful film
that elicits some very
important emotion in all of us
about the urgency for
change and to serve children
in high need communities.
But unfortunately the film is
based upon I believe the assumption
that most people in our public school
system now are not doing what needs
to be done because they don't
care or they're not motivated
or they're just incapable and that
I believe is way, way off the mark.
If we're not getting the job
done the way it needs to be done
and in many places we're
not getting the job done is
because we don't have
a system in place
to support well meaning educators
who really want to make a difference.
They need more preparation, they
need more opportunities to work
with each other and to share their
practices in a highly accountable way
and they need more time
to work with a whole array
of other support providers
for children,
especially in our high
need communities.
>>In the year 2030 we
have a very hopeful vision
that we believe can be realized
and it's built upon
four emergent realities
and we call them emergent realities
because we're beginning to see bits
of them if you will,
beginning to emerge
and they are what we believe
must be in place if we're going
to have this results
oriented profession
and they include one a new
learning ecology for both students
and teachers that not only provides a
kind of twenty four slash seven just
in time learning environment for
both, but also allow teachers
in particular with new tools and
new software and new smart phones
that we haven't even imagined, a
way to account for who's learning,
who's not, why and also help
the public understand the kind
of ambitious goals that
we're trying to achieve.
We also believe that as teachers work
more in cyber space there's going
to be a greater need for teachers to
work in brick and mortar buildings
that have become twenty four slash
seven kind of hubs of the community.
So we're calling for
emergent reality too
that to have teachers working
both in and out of cyber space.
We also believe as our third emergent
reality that more teachers need
to work as a team and we
ought to strategically recruit
and place teachers according to
their strengths and the needs
of the children they serve.
But also build a profession
that makes it much more possible
for teachers to kind of move in
and out of different positions,
in and out of different
school districts,
in and out of different roles at
different points in their career.
A much more differentiated career
pathway built on the needs of kids
and then finally to drive it all
is our emergent reality number four
which is all about teacherpreneurs,
teacherpreneurs are those teachers
who are out best, best
classroom practitioners
who teach regularly children,
never lose that touch
because they are working
with children
and serving them on a regular basis.
But they have time,
space, geography and reward
to spread their expertise again
in and out of cyber space.
>>The first thing I would say is
find other like minded colleagues,
it is not easy because I know you're
working very, very hard every day
to serve the needs of kids in your
community, but there are plenty
of other teachers who really
want something different
and they're beginning to kind
of organize themselves both
formally and informally.
Find those that actually
have the focus that you have,
the hopes that you have, the dreams
that you have and begin to learn
from each other and to organize.
I would also ask teachers
to go to their unions
and tell them it is time
to change dramatically.
We want you as you union leaders to
turn our organizations into much more
like professional deals, where the
focus is on teaching and learning
and where the unions themselves
could actually help broker these
relationships in and out of cyber
space and to demand excellence
but also support excellence
amongst all of us.